left again Fabby and just while we wait
for that result to tick in it's incoming
any moment now we see the Armageddon
game begin with Magnus Carlson and Anish
Gary Magnus with white will we see a
repeat of the earlier clash in the
Catalan
quick moves to start with no this time
it's the nimzo Indian and the queen C2
variation where white gets the bishop
pair but White's Queen forced around the
board a bit and very classical yeah
theoretical stuffed Judith
yep and the Knight coming in to attack
the Queen Another Pawn structure has
stabilized in the center
Magnus employed this variation recently
if I recall uh this line with C takes D5
didn't have a great reputation uh sorry
Magnus trading pawns a couple of moves
ago it didn't have a great reputation
for a long time but suddenly it's come
back into fashion
and I remember some clashes between
Fabiano and Hikaru in this line gets
very very sharp Magnus clearly has done
his homework and a niche pausing
can't afford too many long things in an
Armageddon he's been caught unawares by
this opening choice and in the meanwhile
Fabiano has resigned Shakura does walk
away with three points very important
three points for chakra who was at the
tail end of the tournament and now as
you said you did anything can happen
it's getting close yeah suddenly
Fabiano's four-point lead in the
tournament might be cut down to one
point if Hikaru wins his classical
encounter yeah anything can happen now
indeed and meanwhile something should
happen for initials any move is better
than none at this point he spent one
minute over one minute on this move
um he wants to decide how to react on
that because after that he's going to be
probably pretty fast the next moves
sacrifice the pawn for compensation
let's see whether is he going to be
really having enough compensation in
this game
yeah and Magnus knows what to do of
course he did not hesitate at all he
grabbed the pawn and here black has to
decide how to compensate you need to be
quick you need to get pieces into the
game while all of White's King side
pieces are still asleep
of course Queen exchange and unleash his
game is in so many other games this is
what we've seen but I think this is the
good move and then play Rook C2 looking
for counter chance
and the compensation will be
pretty obvious but I'm sure that black
will have to make accurate moves
two options for white either you keep
your Bishop alive or you save a bit of
time by capturing this Black Knight you
give yourself a Tempo but on the
downside you don't have the bishop pass
the Magnus Retreats back to F4 and he
had that Rook is going to land any
moment now there we go Rook to C2
how does white evict those black pieces
the Black Knight in the center can be
kicked away question mark though
attached to that move
because Magnus does immediately play F3
Knight has to go back to F6 yeah that's
kind of a painful news
yeah I wonder whether Anish should have
finessed this maybe played a move like
G5 first maybe G4 is coming I remember
this because the black Bishop can go to
G6 because Rook C1 immediately with some
tactics and if the bishop has to move
back to E6 then Rook B1 will be possible
and then E3 Bishop D3 comes
yeah slowly but surely white can affect
those black pieces out of his half he's
already kicked back the Knight and
Bishop I love your move Judith there
Rook B1 Magnus loves it too I think he's
just played it and two moves before
Magnus establishes full stability E3
Bishop D3 and then it's just an extra
pawn and Bishop here well this is
absolutely a home prep for Magnus I
believe this was a great trap it was a
trap and it had been played before and
it was just a careless moment from Anish
and once again Magnus being very Wiley
with his opening choices and now the
bishop does come to D3 The Rook is
kicked back
but as David and Judah have been
highlighting white is simply material up
with a great position and to boot
and Anish looks away from the board and
disgust not liking what he's done even
if Magnus didn't have the extra E3 Pawn
I think he would still be a big favorite
in this game just because white has full
control Bishop pair white opposite
exactly that things are not going well
to have such a position against Magnus
spawn down Bishop pair he's going to be
playing King F2 I think simply and
eventually E4
I had some bad experience against Magnus
back in Vikings saying some
similarly I have a phone up but just the
position was
was not good
yeah and that's the thing drew that you
mentioned the strategy getting the
Queen's off as early as possible it
works against most people but against
Magnus uh maybe one of the exceptions uh
he loves these types of positions as
well uh when there's no risk no
complications just slowly improving the
extra Pawn just a bonus
extra three minutes also can't hurt for
Magnus Carlson I think it would be a
bigger shock of the tournament if Magnus
didn't convert the advantage from here
get re-looking away again he's got his
pieces of nice squares but they can go
no further yeah see how annoyed he is
with the position having gone the board
yeah and it's maybe a new experience for
Gary it's rare to see him kind of lost
out of the opening ever let alone uh
kind of after 15 20 moves
disaster and Magnus just taking his time
he'll improve the white Rook on each one
he'll start playing moves like H4
first he lines up
at some point he might play A4 B3 kick
away the black knight from C4
and black will have no more counterplay
well why sorry black will have some tiny
hope in the fact that Magnus is in a
must-win situation so if Magnus for some
reason squanders away his Advantage then
okay
it's okay
but uh okay well a niche cementing his
Knight on C4
this is good strategy it's very
difficult to recommend anything for a
niche other than just to make his pieces
better and just
hope for the best I realize that hope is
not a great plan in general I hope that
kills you
but still
it's something yeah and some small
threats Knight takes B2 occasionally in
the air uh the Black Knight hopping out
the way but yeah it's it's the type of
position you just have to play annoying
moves that's what I try and do in Blitz
when things are going wrong but your
opponent doesn't have to be too much
time just confuse them or at least block
their plans block their plans block
their plans until they get frustrated
that's the only hope now you can see on
the camera I've never seen a niche this
devastated this annoyed at himself
before yeah because it's just after 10
moves or so it was obvious that he is
going to go behind the material he's
picked up the bishop up
fumbling the pieces in ish
we see a trade there white tonight has a
beautiful Square on C3 now
what is magnus's plan he just bypasses
the pawn
wow trying to create a past B Pawn if
black doesn't capture on passant now
then white tonight will sit on C3
forever with a nice blockade we see a
trade opposite color Bishops at least
but small solace
still a pawn up
okay everything coming off the board
well Mike Magnus certainly has his eyes
on the B6 Pawn
style time for
the bishop to get into the game perhaps
Retreat to D7 support the advance of the
B Pawn but nope he's pushed his H Pawn
but they always say when you're
struggling exchange pieces exchange
pawns sorry the problem for a niche is
that he's simply lost another Pawn now
if if the Black Knight takes back on H5
white has Bishop C7 and the black B Pawn
drops the second issue is even if he
goes defensive and defenses b-pawn he's
going to be tied up paralyzed
immobilized forever
this one's over
let's see sad move King H7 and the E4
will be coming yeah
Magnus first improving his King why not
he turns the pawn no no no no and uh
that's it anisha's had enough and Magnus
takes the Armageddon point and therefore
picks up one and a half points for a
niche